a música é legal né pra mim a música ela
mudou a minha vida eu sou formado em
educação física
treinei 12 anos no handebol é dava aula
o kaiser é formado em publicidade e
propaganda ele tava tudo certo para
trabalhar em agências tinha convites e
tudo mais e 2005 nossos caminhos se
cruzaram
eu estava pensando em organizar um
festival com bandas com as mãos dos meus
amigos pra ver
queria ver meus amigos tocarem queria
que eles pudessem posto é mostrar o
trabalho deles por outras pessoas
e aí um amigo em comum nosso é nos
apresentou
eu pensei pô bacana casa já fez alguns
eventos
seria legal ter um cara do meu lado para
me dar umas dicas nesse evento fazendo
então na verdade isso
depois cresceu né na época a música já
estava dentro da gente mas não comum é
ela simplesmente era diversão
entretenimento que nunca imaginou que a
música seria o nosso trabalho a nossa
vida o nosso tudo que a gente faz hoje é
dentro da música desse festival surgiu a
barba produções nossa produtora de
eventos
há alguns anos depois já surgiu o oitavo
clube ea nossa casa de shows o rock e
dois anos depois do ahoy surgiu o factor
'coffee bar é um café bar aqui em
blumenau
parece que foi tudo muito rápido é mas
na verdade rápido e fácil mas na verdade
só foi rápido né
são só dez anos de história mas não foi
nada fácil é eu trabalhava na parte de
comunicação social é na de manhã e de
tarde estudava à noite o bis estudava de
manhã dava aula de tarde e treinava
handebol noite então após as 22 horas
era quando a gente se encontrava e
começar a desenvolver os trabalhos da
produtora
criar eventos discutir ideias fazer
divulgação e às vezes segui a madrugada
dentro assim e foi bem difícil mas a
gente não passou por um perrengue não
passou fome
a gente sempre teve a segurança o teto
da casa nossos pais a gente poder se
dedicar muito bem a isso né
o nosso primeiro festival ele foi feito
com 1 com a ajuda de custo que ganhava
como atleta eu peguei todo aquele
salário ganho aquele mês e investir no
festival foi os r$200 mais bem
investidos da minha vida
obviamente o festival não custou 200
reais
mas se essa grana que a gente tinha que
colocar na frente pra casa aceitar e
fazer o evento e conforme o evento fosse
rolando a gente ia pagando o restante
das coisas
isso claro se ele der certo ele deu os
r$200 voltaram pra mim sobrou 200 reais
a dona caixinha o próximo evento foi lá
a gente fez até r$200 a caixinha mais
200 reais e assim a gente foi
trabalhando e juntando o a grana e todo
o normal pra quando a gente imaginasse
que poderia ter o nosso próprio espaço
mas mesmo assim olhando por cima ainda
parece tudo muito romantizado né porque
na verdade não tem como não ser
está falando uma história de 10 anos que
é curta e que está dando certo mas o que
a gente quer fazer aqui agora é passar
uma mensagem pra vocês não conta não da
nossa história é passar a mensagem vocês
usando a nossa história que a gente quer
dizer é que vocês querem fazer alguma
coisa pra vocês
para os outros que impactem vocês os
outros o meio que vocês vivem qualquer
coisa seja na música eu não quer coisa
vocês precisam fazer alguma coisa vocês
precisam começar a fazer alguma coisa a
gente fez várias coisas
algumas deram certo outras nem tanto
algumas a gente teve que jogar bola pra
frente e sair correndo ficou pela metade
foi fazendo depois como dava
mas a gente vai fazendo e sempre quando
a gente tenha 11 uma discussão sobre uma
coisa que vai dar certo não vai dar
certo
sempre determina na mesma frança só tem
um jeito de a gente saber se vai dar
certo é fazendo se a palavra o verbo
fazer não tiver ali do ladinho colado
não adianta nada eu não tô dizendo vocês
pegarem agora comprar uma kombi botar
todos os melhores amigos vocês dentro e
sair pelo brasil fazendo show que vai
dar certo ou que vão abrir uma produtora
o próximo facebook primeira vez vão
fazer vai ser com bandas internacionais
de dantesco
não é isso que quero dizer pra vocês não
é simples assim
mas se vocês querem fazer alguma coisa
dessa forma que impacto nas pessoas
vocês precisam fazer uma coisa começar a
fazer alguma coisa não tem culpa nos
outros não têm culpa do tempo a gente
estava trabalhando até sete e meia da
manhã eu estava aqui as 10 hoje novo a
gente faz coisas não espera pelos outros
têm que fazer alguma coisa
bom nós fizemos entrava de cabeça nesse
mundo a música é o motivo nosso trabalho
é o que faz a gente acordar todo dia e
trabalhar e se dedicar a isso é muito
legal saber que o nosso trabalho assim
impacto na vida das pessoas né
quem sabe daqui a alguns anos no futuro
quando não tiver mais nossos
empreendimentos pessoal olhar e ter uma
memória de algum espaço à de alguma
vivência uma festa que foi ou alguma
empresa um pouco mais forte que teve
nesse espaço é muito legal saber que
isso tem a um espaço na memória dessas
pessoas está impactando de alguma forma
né
pode ter diversas formas que pode estar
em um dia ruim que acordou mal pode
noite curtir uma festa encontrar os
amigos fazer uma coisa legal pode
conhecer alguém novo que que mexe com o
coração a outro pode ter uma vivência
que a gente oportuniza de tudo conhecer
o ídolo teu nenhum evento nosso isso é
muito bacana
são essas e muitas outras formas que a
gente sente que o nosso trabalho ele
impacta em que se manifesta na vida das
outras pessoas
a gente tem uma das histórias é que que
a gente vai somando durante essa vida
toda que são muito legais
a gente lembra com carinho de uma
história de um cara que ia todo final de
semana no bar todo final de semana toda
a semana se encostava no mesmo canto do
balcão ficava lá e falava pra gente como
é legal falar com ele adorava o bar
curtia muito era tudo muito legal as
bandas tal papear e ele sempre falava
que era preciso trazer um amigo meu aqui
trazendo eu me conhecer mas ele é um
cara mais caseiro e tal é um dia
conseguiu convencer o amigo dele e levou
o amigo dele lá e aí realmente o cara é
o cara mais que é tão e tal mas com o
tempo ele foi curtindo curtindo bairro
conhecendo as pessoas ali e tal ou tal
todo final de semana os caras lá todo
final semana e aí num dia simplesmente
eles não apareceram e por meses não
apareceram mais
a gente ficou se perguntando se a gente
tinha feito alguma coisa que tinha
desagradado eles né
não sabia e aí uns meses depois apareceu
o amigo que é tão lá no bar de novo
sozinho ele chegou lá se encostou no
mesmo canto ea gente ficou olhando e se
for o caso vamos um chapéu pulava se que
aconteceu e aí ele contou pra gente que
o amigo dele tinha falecido num acidente
de carro e que por isso eles não tinham
mais vindo nem ele né
e que ele estava ali naquele dia
simplesmente porque o barco fazia
lembrar e sentiu amigo dele mais próximo
ele falou cara ele amava isso aqui eu
sinto ele aqui do meu lado até uma
história que um cliente veio solicitar
pra gente um cliente que há hoje em dia
se tornou um homem muito próximo já ele
tinha uma espécie de um tumor no cérebro
e precisava passar por uma delicada
cirurgia a cirurgia ele usava raspar o
cabelo e ele e não queria fazer isso em
casa ele veio e disse pra gente
ele foi um pedido dele era que ele
pudesse rasgar o cabelo dentro da nossa
casa no final da festa
depois que a gente fez no final da festa
juntamos os amigos dele ea gente ainda
tomando uma cerveja todo mundo à época
pelo dele fosse uma coisa muito marcante
que acredito que para ele foi muito
significativo como foi pra gente né
tem outras histórias cria uma noite fez
111 artistas de blues o cara muito bom
só que não deu e quase ninguém no bar 20
pessoas ea gente ficou já imaginando
cara com infosys isso com as pessoas
amanhã vai ter várias críticas lá por
foi um pouco chato foi um fracasso e na
verdade aconteceu foi o contrário no
outro dia a gente recebeu um e-mail de
um cara agradecendo o que para ele foi o
melhor
show de blues que ele viu na vida dele
aquela noite a gente impactou aquele
cara no meio de 20 pessoas apenas com o
melhor show de blues que ele viu na vida
dele ele nunca vai esquecer a gente tem
outras histórias também mais românticas
né a casais que se conheceram no nossos
espaços se apaixonaram a em questão se
teve um casal específico desconhecidos
nós conheceram lá nos conheciam se
apaixonaram e eles resolveram se casar
dentro da casa ver o casamento deles lá
e antes do arroio mudar de endereço
ainda no antigo endereço no último dia
de funcionamento eles apareceram logo a
filha deles pra ela conhecer o lugar que
eles se viram pela primeira vez a gente
tem um cliente também é muito específico
que é uma alemão é muito querido
ele veio para blumenau há quatro anos
atrás e ele acabou conhecendo o arroz e
é um cara altamente viajado conhece
vários bares várias culturas e ele não
cansa de falar para todo mundo que o
arroio melhor para quem já foi na vida
dele
ele fala isso todo dia e ele teve a
oportunidade de voltar para o brasil
agora o final de 2015
e ele botou e tina o itinerário queria
fazer né na rede social ele voltou para
são paulo para florianópolis para
curitiba quero rever o pessoal total mas
deixou muito bem enfatizou lado o senhor
dia tal eu quero estar na rua e quero
conhecer o novo espaço a gente tem
outras histórias também que impactou
muito a gente é talvez às vezes não
impactando o público mais impacta gente
também
a gente teve oportunidade de fazer a
trazer problemas ao uma dupla de
americano
dois americanos a figuras lendárias já
do da da cena punk e hoje em dia eles
rodam o mundo com um violão fazendo show
funk
eles não vêm com o técnico não vêm com o
equipamento não fazem muitas exigências
é muito tranquilo e e foi um dos shows
mais legais que já produziu nossa vida
eles deram uma aula pra gente do povo
edificante é poder trabalhar e atinge as
pessoas com uma coisa que tu gosta fazer
música
é mas talvez nenhuma dessas histórias
sejam tão impactante quanto a história
do do processo judicial que o arroz
sofreu
é é é que fez a gente tem que mudar eles
lugar é resumidamente a gente tinha um
vizinho que não gostava da gente não
gostava do fato de ter um bar perto da
casa dele
por mais que a gente conversar por mais
que a gente tomasse atitudes pra arrumar
qualquer mulher que está chegando pra
ele o isolamento acústico da casa 100%
tudo quanto mais bacanas solistas com o
problema do carro problema do cara a
gente era é menos ele ajudava
ele queria fechar o bar era o intuito
dele e na verdade assim esse processo
durou quatro anos
o processo judicial de quatro anos pra
gente um processo inútil né porque a
gente é tudo certo todos os alvarás a
pendurados e sempre acontecia alguma
coisa na esfera jurídica que inverte o
jogo e o bairro sofre as consequências a
gente foi interditado várias e várias
vezes ea primeira vez que ele foi
interditado o nosso palco lá que nós
podíamos abrir o bar não podia ter banda
foi em 2011 isso foi muito forte impacto
muito na gente porque querendo ou não a
gente era ainda dois guris de 25 anos
que estavam no limite entre dois caras
empresários cuidando do seu o seu
empreendimento e dois guris de 25 anos
que é brincando de fazer música
isso eu tenho uma bomba sempre a gente
sabe que a gente pensou cara eu todo
aquele tempo todo que a gente fez vai
por água abaixo agora vamos largar isso
aí vamos fazer uma coisa mais fácil que
a gente está se dedicando tanto isso
aqui e o que a gente achou que ia ser um
fracasso e destruir com a gente na
inverteu
quando a aplicação da interdição
aconteceu na internet explodiu era um
muita mensagem
a gente foi capa do jornal de maior
circulação da cidade dois dias seguidos
a gente foi uma das matérias mais lidas
do ano o nosso algoz ligou para o jornal
perguntando quanto que a gente pagou
a capa do jornal sabe então eu digo isso
mostrou pra gente enquanto que a gente
faz impactava na vida de algumas pessoas
e quanto é importante o bairro não
fechar
seria quase o iso o nosso não nos
levantarmos aquela porrada e ir pra
frente
sabe manter o lugar do jeito que der
para manter a gente decidiu então
continuar e com essa suspensão de shows
ao vivo na casa
a gente tinha que se reinventar e
procurar coisa nova pra fazer cada
evento né
o xará idéias novas novas interações com
o público é uma das idéias que que a
gente aplicou no barco foi uma das mais
bacanas a foi a transmissão de um show
na casa
a gente não podia fazer show ao vivo
nosso palco mas a gente não tinha nenhum
impedimento legal de por exemplo
transmitiu a kim yu-na o rock in rio na
multishow nossa nossa tv
então a gente fez a seguinte linha
lógica a gente pegou uma banda aqui do
metal
vou tocar num estúdio aqui perto e
transmitir o show no telão do palco do
ahoy
aí deu tudo certo e assim ó entre essas
e várias outras idéias
o público ou sempre foi muito fiel
e por incrível que pareça abraçar essa
causa absurdamente onde teve mais rápido
na casa em dia sem banda do que
contratações formais nem cubanas é então
assim é eu posso onde posso enumerar
cinco bairros de blumenau que fechou em
menos de um ano por falta de público ea
gente ficou por mais do que esse período
sem poder usar nossa principal produto
que era música ao vivo é com a casa
aberta e com um público expressivo assim
então é isso é muito bacana
é dessas e de outras formas que a gente
sente que o nosso trabalho ea música
impacto na vida das pessoas e os vezes
fico pensando que que louco seria se eu
simplesmente anos atrás tivesse decidido
pelo fácil pelo simples tivesse decidido
não fazer alguma coisa
saca tanto de vida tanto de experiências
compartilhadas com várias pessoas
inclusive estou aqui que eu teria
perdida que não teria não teria tido né
e hoje é bem evidente que a gente não
faz música a gente usa a música para
criar experiências para vocês né e com e
criamos locais onde a música está
conectada com as pessoas e as pessoas se
identificam com a música e com o local é
uma coisa que sempre acontece é todo ano
o turma de faculdade sempre colado com a
gente para fazer trabalho sobre o usando
barba que a gente queria mostrar um
videozinho aqui pra vocês tá de um
desses trabalhos vai ter uma
participação mais pecar uma meta lata de
dizer namorar
por isso a gente tem um carinho muito
grande por também que isso é bom
a música tem essa característica própria
de aproximar as pessoas e ouvir as
pessoas em torno do ritual que é fazer
escutar música eo a oi é um templo na
ele proporciona esse espaço para as
pessoas se reunirem se aproximarem
celebrar
sucesso pra cacau e acaba virando na
segunda casa segundo lugar de trabalho
eu já baseadas em quem sabe fazem sentir
uma faca foi sempre uma festa
o legal é sempre importante nisto namoro
e ele já freqüentava o lugar ele conhece
e que dêem prazer nosso lugar de
encontro de sempre a gente veículos
nunca deixou de andar muito importante
pra gente foi contra 21
e agora
é um lugar onde eu sei que vou jogar o
que chamou a atenção e amor
só aconteceu porque decidiu fazer alguma
coisa sabe brigar